they're trying to ban Tick Tock this is
wild they're trying to get rid of tick
tock because it is a tool of the Chinese
surveillance State and not the American
surveillance State and they're like this
is the bad one unlike Facebook which my
aunt went on looking at casserole
recipes and is now full Q Anon and
estranged from her family Tick Tock CEO
Xiao Chu was grilled by lawmakers does
tick tock access the home Wi-Fi network
tell me what your company does are you
watching my babies change Coco's man
that we do not do anything that is
beyond any industry Norms I believe the
answer to our customers are you getting
to the toaster or not
can it [__] with the toaster yes or no
I'm asking you a direct question
zaoching
let me ask you a question
our kids were doing great before this
app came along they were shooting up
schools and doing heroin